with across the spider verse releasing
soon in the trend of Multiverse
crossovers showing no signs of stopping
soon fourth snake Diego Rivera panels to
pixels and yours truly are delving into
the history of spider-verse and showing
you the ups and downs of the concept
even though I didn't love the Ultimate
Spider-Man animated series I did make
sure to point out that its attempts at
adapting the spider-verse concept were
some of my favorite episodes of the show
it always felt like ultimate excelled
more at Crossovers and less on
developing its main cast members so you
can bet a whole 4 episode Arc devoted
nothing but crossovers is where its
strengths really shine in the first
episode of The Ark Spidey finds out that
Green Goblin is planning to steal the
DNA of the other Spider-Man variants in
the Multiverse for nefarious purposes
possibly clones hopefully not he
forcefully turns electro into a power
source and goes on his way with our hero
in tow to well
fail at stopping him like six
consecutive times like an idiot but
there's no story if he's too confident
so we gotta let it slide like slide I
like the show spider verse more than a
lot of the comic versions because it
keeps a tight grasp on Peter being the
main character and the focus of the
adventure I always felt like the comic
events started to include too many
characters at once and collapse under
the weight because there was like too
many spider people to keep track of in
one image
plus it's really straightforward that
Spidey is going from Universe to
universe and meeting one variant at a
time instead of walking into a room with
like 90 of them and most of them are in
the same outfit over the arc he goes to
two universes per episode and sometimes
the art style will change drastically
sometimes it's pretty subtle
according to protocol this is the part
where we are supposed to fight but that
seems inane predictable and a waste of
resources so let's not just say we did
just hang on and keep low and don't
worry I've been doing this a little
longer than you
foreign
first up is a cool 3D art style in the
futuristic world of 2099. I do love the
look of this 3D art style here but the
actual animation is a bit clunky
sometimes the moves don't translate well
between shots like I'm not understanding
the poses here and this just feels a
little stiff don't get me wrong I would
love more 3D Spider-Man animation I just
wish it looked as fluid as the keyframes
in that 2003 show the models were lower
quality but the movement was buttery
smooth and slick as hell it seems like
the spider-verse movie is the best of
both of these by having a cool
cel-shaded 3D style and smooth animation
movements across all of these segments
there's a recurring theme of the Prime
Spidey helping his counterparts get a
confidence boost and find their way back
to the light if they're in the process
of quitting the superhero Biz all these
crossovers are too short to develop the
characters too well but they succeeded
getting the point across in the time
available so we start to see Spidey
inspiring Miguel to keep up the good
work and
carrying on his legacy
and uh
I'm tired I don't want to record this
right now are you dising
that the traditional costume is red and
blue as if what Miguel is wearing is not
also red and blue and this will forever
haunt me you know Venom meets Miguel in
the comics and says his costume is
ripped off from his also Flipside
assumes Spider-Man and Venom fused into
a single entity because of the color
scheme
okay we can all agree that it factually
is a black and red costume regardless of
your opinion on if that's better or
worse than it being blue I don't like
talking about this all the time but you
keep bringing it up and I feel obligated
to respond while we're at it storms 90s
costume is silver not white the second
half of this episode is unfortunately
the worst one in the arc instead of
using Mayday they create a spider girl
that's just a gender swap version of
Peter in a universe where every person
is the opposite gender
costume a boy pretending to be Spidey
now I've seen everything boys can't be
Spider-Girl you'll just hurt yourself
I'll hurt what well her voice acting is
pretty crap so I can believe she's a
variant of this chuckle all right
the only confusing part is that she's
incredibly sexist towards Peter for
being a boy and it's weird because I
genuinely couldn't see him acting like
that to her if the roles were reversed
and she ended up on his world instead
maybe it was meant to Echo Mayday
meeting Peter via time travel and him
being a bit of a chauvinistic dumbass
but this take on Peter just like isn't
like that he's a lot of annoying
irritating punchable things but a
meninist is thankfully not one of them
I'll give them points for their
alternate world's Green Goblin being a
more traditional one with gadgets and a
costume instead of the green skin
mutated version from the Ultimate Comics
hey this is pumpkin bombs there's not a
single pumpkin bomb anywhere else in
this whole show next episode The Noir
crossover is decent with Peter teaching
that Spidey to be less of a loner and
allow his cast of Side characters back
into his life again
though they don't do much with the art
style other than making it black and
white the episode gets more colorful and
creative when he meets Spider-Man
I take the exaggerated toony look of
this world and the more slapstick
physics they've
they was in the spider ham World correct
like iron Mouse and Captain America oh
they goofed on spider Ham's costume and
his origin of being a spider bitten by a
radioactive Pig I think that's
infinitely funnier and I'm glad the
movie got that right in my initial video
of this series I complained that
ultimate Spidey never mentioned that he
was a pig once too to him but it turns
out he does and I just missed that line
somehow I've even walked a mile in your
hooves that time Loki turned me into a
pig what
it's it's 125 episodes to keep
track of it's okay though because it
spurred a lot of comments to correct me
and boosted video engagement so I've
elected to get something minor incorrect
in every video to help the channel grow
next up is spider night medieval
deadland voiced by former Spider-Man
voice actor Josh Keaton other than the
novelty of the returning Spidey voice
actor from a previous cartoon there's
not to say here I guess medieval Doc Ock
is kind of cool the big selling point of
this episode is actually the latter half
when Brooklyn Spider-Man shows up I I'm
just gonna start calling him Brooklyn
Spider-Man to shut up you dorks inhaling
pure copium thinking he's not Spider-Man
too and I'll double down on this too
calling him kid arachnid is stupid and
if you prefer that then you're stupid
too and you should eat your own hands
for sustenance so I can't see you type
such tomfoolery anymore you can't post
the same irritating bad opinion over and
over with two hook hands you this
segment with Brooklyn Spidey is where I
felt like the spider-verse movie started
taking notes the most it's just more
streamlined than the way adult Peter met
miles in the spider men book though some
moments from that did make it into the
movie too more or less
some shots and story Beats from this and
the following spider-verse episodes seem
to get folded into the spider-verse
movie pretty perfectly thus solidifying
my opinion that these episodes are some
of the best the show had to offer like
that Dragon Green Goblin design both
Spider-Man meeting at Peter's grave and
a lot of the lessons miles learns from
Peter you may not have been able to save
the other Peter Parker but today you
saved me but it's okay to be afraid as
long as you as long as I don't let fear
get in the way of doing what's right
I'll try to be the best Peter Parker
Spider-Man I can be you don't have to be
Peter Parker to be Spider-Man Miles
Morales is just fine
I've gone on record as thinking Brooklyn
Spider-Man's initial run was pretty
underwhelming with its lackadaisical
characterization but this episode sees
him start to find his place as a
character a little more and the
Insomniac Games pushed him a little
further with some fresh ideas and then
the movie came along and knocked it out
of the park
it's like a game of telephone where
after adapting it enough times they
finally made miles super cool and
interesting to me after all the
bendicisms were shaken off
then the comics got good too God I wish
Peter's books were doing as well as
miles hey you want to hear
something cool
all right take off your headphones and
turn up the volume it's okay I'll wait
all right you got it all right okay Xbox
off Alexa off PlayStation off Siri shut
down Cortana off okay Google how to
remove genital warts four-parter comes
to a close when Goblin and Spidey make
it home to their original Universe we
learned Goblin's master plan was to use
the spider DNA to give himself a massive
power boost
at the cost of turning into a giant
gross tarantula thing plus he figures
out Peter's secret identity from all the
obvious clues that this brainlet is left
along the way
wait a minute
Peter Porker sounds kind of like
hmm
it was Peter Palmer all along after some
lackluster voice acting from our lead he
calls in the cast of other guys voiced
by actual voice actors that have Talon
plus spider girl we get a semi-decent
final fight with Electro where the
characters get to play off each other
well and act as a team and it's it's
pretty nice as far as adaptations of
comic arcs go in this show it really
doesn't have anything to do with the
comic spider verse which is funny
because apparently this same version of
him appeared there too
ended the comic by hinting at his own
spider verse in the future which implies
that happened before this Arc in the
show but the show itself doesn't
acknowledge it much like how Insomniac
Spider-Man will never mention spider
Gavin it was just an adjacent Universe
it's not the same Ultimate Spider-Man
from the cartoon it's like another
universe that was created 12 inches to
the left it's like how Spider-Man
Unlimited can be killed by Moreland and
show up in Spider geddon and the new
movie there's an unlimited number of
Drake Bell Spider-Mans all telling the
same terrible jokes across the
Multiverse maybe even one voiced by a
better VA but we'll save that one for
tomorrow
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign